all right if I if I could have your
attention I'd like to introduce our
speaker tonight this is the last in a
series of lectures that we've heard this
summer this nuclear summer John Gatos
very generously come to speak with us
tonight about nuclear weapons and grand
strategy I'll just say something about
this program that is concluding today
it's all been made possible by the
generosity of Roger Hertog in the Hertog
foundation so I want to thank Roger for
that support and I also want to thank
many students who have taken part the
tremendous research that they've done
and I want to thank to all of those in
addition to the students who've worked
on this program and to tomato what it is
as many of you know will be continued
again next summer with a new subject
next summer we'll be looking at the
history of public health and how it can
help us prepare for the next pandemic so
this program as many of you already know
and maybe you've already heard maybe
even once too often this program the
idea of it is to see what happens when
you blow the walls down in a university
and liberate the people who work there
to work on the problems of the
contemporary world and use history in
thinking about the future and so we
brought together political scientists
historians policymakers without regard
for discipline but more for the purpose
of thinking about how these ideas and
the research they've done and the
knowledge they've created can help us in
thinking about the world as it is in the
world as it may be so I welcome you all
tonight but I would also ask you to stay
tuned to continue some of the some of
you've already seen our website but look
again in the months ahead as we announce
the program next year and if you're
interested in participating this program
if you're a student at Columbia or at
other universities whether an
undergraduate or a graduate student or
if you know such a student who you think
might benefit from this program then of
course all the more reason then to have
a look at what we're doing so thank you
and and thank you finally in addition to
Roger Hertog to the Saltzman Institute
for co-sponsoring this lecture series
all those that the Institute worked so
hard to make this work and also to SEPA
for providing this beautiful venue as
they do every week thank you again
now let me introduce Don Gatos John for
those of you who've ever read anything I
think it's safe to say anything at all
about the history of 20th century
American foreign relations if you
haven't read the the work of John Gatos
if you haven't seen his work referenced
in the notes I think you you if you read
anything for the last 20 or 30 years
would have read something that was
either inspired by and formed by or
perhaps inflamed by the work of this man
he's been at the very center of
controversy yes but also critical and
important research and trying to
understand the history of America's
engagement with the world but his work
beyond his scholarship and I won't list
the long list of books that are part of
the Canon now that works that graduate
students read in trying to learn about
this history I won't list those books
for you because many of you are all too
familiar with them perhaps if you've
been trying to read all of them and
preparing for your exams and so on so
let me just say something else about him
he's also one of the founders along with
Paul Kennedy of the Brady Johnson
program and grand strategy at Yale
University
this is a bold program and also for some
anyway a controversial one but its
premise on the idea that since students
will be leading the United States and
other countries in the future are a
captive audience between the ages of 18
and approximately 28 then they're
professors over to them and they owe it
to the country in the world
to be sharing with them not just their
ideas the research but classic readings
in grand strategy from Sun Zoo to
Clausewitz and so on that will help them
think not just about the moment but more
generally about means and ends about how
the United States might marshal all of
its means to achieve large ends in the
world it is a bold program and it's been
an important and influential one and in
some ways
it was also one of the programs that
inspired this program this nuclear is
summer and the Hertog global strategy
initiative so there are many reasons why
I'm so happy to have John Gaddis with us
here tonight those are just a few of
them so thank you John for coming thank
you all for coming - thanks very much
Matt the I have my colleagues Paul
Kennedy and Charlie Hill and I they're
three of us actually who are involved in
teaching grand strategy had the
interesting experience last week of
attending a conference in Newport at the
Naval War College which is where we got
the idea for the grand strategy course
because Newport has been teaching
something called the lucida T's
curriculum since the early 1970s and our
conference was on the teaching of grand
strategy arrayed behind us
the three of us who teach grand strategy
we're about four or five of our former
students including professor or Connelly
and one of the things that struck me
about this as the discussion proceeded
is that we may have been teaching grand
strategy but we certainly have not
succeeded in teaching deference this
became pretty obvious because bombs were
being thrown by our students up in our
direction for the whole thing and we
were dodging flak from our students and
I thought about that afterwards and I
thought that's the way it should be
that's what a relationship between a
professor and a student and it's what
the relationship between professor
Connelly and his students should
certainly be that controversy is what
it's all about and clumps are not
what it's all about so each generation
is different each of these grand
strategy programs I'm happy to say are
different and there's much to welcome
there is much to glory in in these
differences it still was unsettling to
have the bombs thrown to the extent that
they were though
and that was gratifying I guess I'm
telling myself you see that grin you see
what I mean
okay I also had an email a couple of
days ago from my friend John Coleman who
is sitting over there who said I hear
you're giving a lecture at Columbia and
I wrote back and said I think it's a
seminar actually John and he said well
it was advertised as a lecture and I
looked again rather carefully and
discovered yes it was advertised as a
lecture and this is something more than
a seminar the number of people who are
here today so I have to say I wanted
something up fairly quickly relating to
the topic without having as much
preparation time as I would like to have
for a lecture but that's my own fault
from simply assuming that in the summer
people don't do lectures I've tried to
make a habit of that but somehow this
says eluded me this anyway with that
qualification and some extent that
apology or to talk about the theme of
nuclear weapons and grand strategy which
I take to have been the theme of this
whole summer project more or less and
I'd like to do it in the context of what
might be called concluding remarks I
think this is the last lecture is that
correct man of the series to try to back
off and look at how several grand
strategists have dealt with nuclear
weapons
in the past make a few suggestions about
what this history might suggest about
the future the future as it was being
run in the grand strategy in the nuclear
weapons crisis scenario that we just
wound up about 20 minutes ago was grim
indeed the students had managed to blow
up just about everybody to the point
that the only person left to become
president that was the role I was
playing just 30 minutes ago was the
unfortunate Secretary of Education who
had suddenly and unexpectedly been
elevated to the presidency because in
this scenario the whole rest of the
cabinet and president and patna had been
wiped out that's a very grim scenario
our students are never that
bloody-minded at yeah I can tell you New
York I understand and I was thinking
about that in three separate taxi cabs
today so with all that said I want to
talk about three grand strategists of
nuclear weapons one of whom had never
heard of nuclear weapons
one of whom thought a great deal about
nuclear weapons but didn't really know
what to do about them or couldn't figure
out what to do about them and one of
whom was actually in a position to do
something about them all of them agreed
I think on what the basis of a grand
strategy for nuclear weapons ought to be
but they were so widely separated in
time and in one instance also certainly
by temperament that it I think would
have astonished them have you been able
to get them together in the same room
and point out how much they agreed with
each other the fact that they did or at
least the proposition that they did
which is the proposition that I want to
put forward this afternoon may suggest
that there is a kind of nuclear logic
that exists that transcends time place
culture circumstance and personality but
all I want to do is suggest this I don't
want to insist on it
because I'm not actually convinced that
it's true I think it's likely but I'm
not sure and I think that phrase but I'm
not sure should probably always attend
any conference or any seminar or any
simulation exercise regarding nuclear
weapons because the element of surprise
and the element of uncertainty and the
element of not being sure is something
that I think always ought to be in our
minds with regard to this topic my three
nuclear strategists are Carl von
Clausewitz George F Kenan and Ronald
Reagan and let me begin by saying
something about each of them and how
they connect to this subject Basel it's
died in 1831 and his great but
incomplete book on war was published
posthumously in 1832 so of course he and
no one else of his generation had ever
heard of nuclear weapons and even a
hundred years later even the early
nuclear physicists had a Hartley begun
to think in the 1930s about the
possibility that the subject they were
dealing with could be weaponized quote
unquote but plasmids did have a concept
of what he called absolute war it's
described in the first few pages of his
great book and he had three criteria for
setting forward what an absolute war
would be like first that it would occur
suddenly and in a manner disconnected
from events taking place in the
political world secondly that it would
consist of a single decisive act or
perhaps a set of simultaneous but
decisive acts and third and most
important that the outcome produced
would
the uninfluenced by prior calculations
of the political situation it was meant
to bring about now fosselman's went on
in the next several hundred pages of
more to explain that absolute war as he
had defined it simply was not possible
the human capacity for overcoming what
he called friction all the things that
can go wrong was the principal reason
for this but there were many other
reasons as well which he discusses in
great detail in that great book but he
also argued that even if absolute war
were possible it would not be desirable
in fact it would be horrible in fact it
would be the worst thing that could
possibly happen because the end result
would be violence for the sake of
violence itself and this in the mind of
plasmids could never be the objective of
a rational state that's what he meant
then by his much misunderstood claim
Clausewitz that quote war is the
continuation of politics by other means
I think perhaps a better way of putting
it might have been that means must be
subordinated to end whether in war or
peace because to do the reverse to
subordinate ends to memes would be to
corrupt ends or not to have identified
ends in the first place
and that would be irrationality for
which Clausewitz
had no time apart from what happened on
a very limited sphere of battle but for
the state irrationality was an alien
concept the assumption of Clausewitz is
that states are the means of organizing
society and the assumption also is that
States must behave rationally otherwise
they cannot exist and by rational what
he means
use this subordination of means to
against war is a continuation of
politics by other means so how did he
talk about absolute war in the first
place well I think he did so because he
saw it as a kind of Platonic ideal form
which meant that reality always fell
short of it strategy involved
calculating by how much it had fallen
short in each of the specific
circumstances that the strategist was
likely to encounter absolute or as fuzzy
wits used it was an analytical tool but
not a physical possibility yet I've
always wondered if either late at night
unable to sleep and then falling asleep
again
but having bad dreams Clausewitz dreamt
about what an absolute war in reality
would look like I can't prove that there
is no Clausewitz dream diary as there is
for George Kennan but I've always
wondered despite two 20th century world
wars the successors to Clausewitz gave
little further consideration to this
problem of absolute war until two
American atomic bombs detonated a
devastated two Japanese cities in August
of 1945 and it's no accident that when
the first serious book appeared
assessing the implications of Hiroshima
and Nagasaki in the spring of 1946 its
editor it was a good Clausewitz 'i'm
bernhard brody and that its title was
the absolute weapon now that brings me
to george kennan who was at that time in
the summer of 1946 just back from
sending a very long telegram from Moscow
his new job was to set up the grand
strategy curriculum the first one ever
really in the United States at the newly
created National War College in
Washington Kenan read Brody
absolute weapon as soon as it came out
he immediately absorbed the central
message of it the best way to avoid
atomic war is to avoid war itself can it
wrote in the notes that he took on Brody
that summer the best way to avoid war is
to be prepared to resort to atomic
warfare that's about as far as George
Kennan got thinking about atomic warfare
and the issues surrounding it for the
next three or four years he had some
other things to do like creating the
strategy of containment presiding over
the Marshall Plan opposing NATO etc etc
there was a lot going on when the
Russians did in fact get the bomb and
tested it in August of 1949 Kennan's
initial reaction was that not much had
changed but that view changed that view
of kenans just two months later when he
learned as many others did at the same
time the theoretical possibility of
building another kind of bomb of
building a thermonuclear weapon which
would be a thousand times more powerful
than the bombs that had been used
against Japan Kennan's tutor in these
matters was JR and J robert Oppenheimer
and the director for the Institute for
Advanced Study which is where Kenan
would wind up spending the last half of
his life and what worried Oppenheimer
and Kenan a lot in the late fall and
early winter of 1949 was a have rapidly
theory as it had been developed by the
nuclear physicist was evolving into the
need for policy choice ie should the
United States respond to the Soviet
atomic bomb by attempting to build its
own super bomb that was the term that
was used at that point it bent
thermonuclear or hydrogen bomb
both Kenan and Oppenheimer said no that
building more atomic bombs would suffice
to achieve deterrence to counter the
Soviet atomic bomb but at the end of
January 1950 as most of you know
President Truman decided that the United
States would have to do more the United
States would have to at least attempt to
construct what later came to be known as
the hydrogen bomb and as it turns out
Stalin's physicists had been hard at
work on their own h-bomb since 1946 so
those who worried that the American
decision would push the Russians into
developing their own h-bomb were behind
what was actually happening the Russians
started doing it first knowing that he
had lost the policy battle on this Kenan
went on in the winter of 1949 and early
1950 to draft the first grand strategic
document the first american grand
strategic document I think on the
thermonuclear age now this was a
characteristic George Kennan memorandum
first of all it was long 79 pages
single-spaced that of course ensured
that nobody read it within government
Paul Nitze who understood these things
much better reduced his recommendations
to two paragraphs which of course became
policy but this was canon it had to be
long and I think he was writing this
document it was titled the international
control of atomic energy not for the
Truman administration so much because he
knew already what the Truman
administration was going to do I think
he wrote it for us largely he wrote it
for posterity he wrote it with a view to
try and set forth some ideas that would
over the long term govern or should
govern how the United States dealt with
a world in which the possibility of
thermonuclear war the possibility of
absolute war
as Clausewitz had understood it was no
longer in the realm of theory but in the
realm of reality canon argued in this
document there was no way in which
nuclear weapons could be made to serve
any rational end beyond that of simply
deterring the outbreak of hostilities
because picking up on Clausewitz who he
had read or at least he had read a
summary of Clausewitz war was a means to
an end not an end in itself it might
involve an end
cannon wrote marked by submission to
some new political will and perhaps to a
new regime of life but an end which at
least did not negate the principle of
life itself and that's what horrified
Canon about relying on thermonuclear
weapons
as early as January 1950 that it could
extinguish life itself later on he's
reading Reinhold Niebuhr on nuclear
weapons whose thoughts similarly and
canon used the analogy of deterrence
nuclear deterrence as being like a child
running through his father's house with
a burning swath of papers it was that
irresponsible you could burn down the
ancestral mansion you could burn down
the common home and this is what Canon
found so outrageous about these weapons
and so profoundly unchristian because
one of the things people don't realize
is how deep how deeply committed Kenan
was to Christianity nuclear weapons
could serve no rational end he wrote and
in a famous passage he explained nuclear
weapons reached beyond the frontiers of
Western civilization to the concepts of
warfare that once were familiar to the
Asiatic hordes they cannot really be
reconciled with a political purpose
directed to shaping rather than to
destroying the lives of the adversary
they failed to take him to pound the
ultimate responsibility of men for one
another it reads like a sermon and it
was MIT I suppose to be a sermon
innocent and then canon in a remarkable
leap of insight found a quote from
Shakespeare I think it's in Henry the
fifth take but degree away on tune that
string and hark what discordant follows
then everything includes in power power
into will will into appetite and
appetite the universal wolf
so doubly seconded with will and power
must perforce make the universal prey
and at last eat himself up so
Shakespeare was a Klaus would see
without point as much to be said days
Kenan thought it vital therefore that we
quote not fall into the error of
initiating or planning to initiate the
employment of these weapons and concepts
thus hypnotizing ourselves into the
belief that they may ultimately serve
some positive national purpose now he
was not arguing here for any unilateral
relinquishment of nuclear weapons some
such devices he thought would have to be
retained for purposes of deterrence and
retaliation he was thinking primarily of
atomic bombs not thermonuclear weapons
well what Kenan was advocating in this
great paper of early 1950 was in
peacetime a posture of what would later
come to be called minimum deterrence
that is restricting the number and the
power of bombs in the American arsenal
strictly to our estimate he wrote as to
what it would take to make attack on
this country or its allies by weapons of
mass destruction
a risky and probably unprofitable and
therefore irrational undertaking for any
adversary should war come he was also
advocating a policy of no first use
which of course would require that the
United States and its NATO allies
significantly beef up their non-nuclear
conventional military capabilities which
they mostly did not have at that time
and third Canon was looking toward the
possibility of opening up even in that
dark period eventual serious
negotiations with the Soviet Union on
the possibility that a common interest
could be found in controlling and
perhaps even eliminating all nuclear
weapons even an imperfect agreement you
wrote would be less dangerous than
leaving the shadow of uncontrolled mass
destruction weapons to lie across the
peoples of the world now like many
cannon ideas there were certain
practical problems with these ideas for
one thing there was no way to know in
the context of early 1950 how minimum
deterrent capabilities should actually
be only five months after cannon
finished his great memorandum after all
Stalin Mao and kim ill sung in the face
of what was still an overwhelming
american superiority in nuclear weapons
unleashed their surprise attack on South
Korea it was not at all clear as well
where the resources would come from to
build up conventional military
capabilities kenan himself had grave
reservations about NSC 68 the great
document in which his alter-ego paul
Nitsa advocated such a strategy and
certainly no one really seriously
believed that the europeans could or
should divert resources from economic
recovery the latter phases of the
Marshall Plan to build up the kind of
conventional military capability that
would have allowed them to equal the
kind of strength that existed on the
side of the Soviet Union nor was it
clear in that period the last years of
Stalin how any agreements might be
reached with the Soviet Union which was
then very much a closed society or how
such agreements if they could be
reached could be verified it's very
interesting that canon back in 1946 and
early 1947 is extremely contemptuous of
the Baruch plan first the Atchison
Lilienthal plant and in the baroque
plant for the international control of
atomic energy and his reasons are
precisely this you can't trust the
Russians there's no way to verify
whether the Russians would be keeping
these agreements or not but what he's
saying in 1950 is that we have to think
ahead perhaps to a very distant future
when it might be possible to trust and
verify it was however chemins haven't
exasperated to his contemporaries but
most intriguing to his biographer to be
better at prophecy than at policy
planning and in the long run people
found their way back to some of the
ideas that he had put forward in this
1950 document Kennan's fundamental
insight that a war fought with nuclear
weapons would make all too real the
class would see and bad dream that it
would in Shakespeare's image turn
appetite into a universal prey that
would eat itself up I think this vision
more than anything else explains the
single greatest surprise about the Cold
War the fact that nuclear weapons were
used twice within three days just as the
Cold War just as the world war was
evolving into a cold war but then
nuclear weapons would not again be used
by anyone for any purpose for the next
four and a half decades of extremely
tense superpower rivalry who would have
predicted that on say August the 10th
1945 a day after Nagasaki
that's one of the most remarkable
developments of the Cold War I've taken
a stab at trying to explain it won't go
into the details here but somehow
without anybody having actively
orchestrated this an awareness of the
physical consequences
and ecological awareness of the
consequences did graduate them emerge
really across all of the different
political categories across all of the
countries that acquired and deployed
nuclear weapons
I think the first moment I've argued
that the first moment comes when the
first thermonuclear weapons were tested
and if you read the accounts of the
American scientists who engineers
witnessing the first American h-bomb
test and the first Soviet engineers and
scientist witnessing the first Soviet
h-bomb test the first in 1952 the second
in 1953 they could be word-for-word the
same both talk about birds being blinded
and blown out of the sky
both were struck by that image and
somehow at that just that point it seems
to me this common sense of common danger
really began to develop for the first
time and it grew so I think it's really
quite remarkable in retrospect that not
just the United States and the Soviet
Union but also the British the French
the Chinese the Israelis the Indians all
learned to treat the nuclear weapons
that they had developed with Klaus wit
Sein respect only one of their leaders
as far as I know had actually read
Clausewitz I think the only person in
the leadership in a leadership position
in the Cold War who had actually read
closets was Dwight Eisenhower who was
forced to read Clausewitz three times by
a martinet of an army major in the
Panama Canal Zone somewhere back in the
1920s and Eisenhower certainly absorbed
Clausewitz very carefully but what's so
interesting is that nobody else had read
Clausewitz and yet people began thinking
in Foxwoods Ian's terms it almost makes
you believe in some kind of mental
telepathy I mean how was it that the
basic message of an unfinished book
inter German a century and a half
earlier could have made its way into the
minds of such diverse leaders as Nikita
Khrushchev or malsuk Toma or Charles de
Gaulle or Gandhi
I mean Indira not Mohandas Golda Meir
Margaret Thatcher and Ronald Reagan and
for a possible explanation on how to
turn to Reagan as the third of the grand
strategists and I should say great grand
stretches then I want to talk about with
regard to nuclear weapons it's hard for
many people to think of Reagan as a
strategist it's hard for many people
still to think of Reagan as anything
more than just a simple-minded actor who
read Lange's for the camera but this is
changing and certainly within the
historical profession the acknowledgment
has begun to dawn on a lot of surprised
historians that Ronald Reagan concealed
a lot of things not the least of which
was an extraordinary political
sensibility and extraordinary
intelligence and extraordinary sense of
grand strategy what you saw with Reagan
was not always what was really there
like most actors Reagan played roles
that were not in accordance with what he
necessarily always believed somebody
else who did the same thing of course
was FDR and so it terrified Kenneth when
Reagan became president and particularly
when during his first term in office he
sought to rebuild American military
strength while calling the Soviet Union
what it really was an evil empire George
Kennan was convinced war was going to
break out at any moment
in this period actually if truth be told
George Kennan was convinced that nuclear
war was about to break out just at any
moment from 1950 through 1989 or
in 91 but he especially thought this in
the early Reagan years in fact though
Reagan really without anybody realizing
clearly at the time certainly not George
Kennan had already begun pushing
American nuclear strategy for the first
time in any comprehensive way in some of
the directions that Kenan in 1950 had
wanted it to go first minimum deterrence
Reagan began with a deceptively simple
question why did there have to be so
many nuclear weapons on each side nobody
had really asked that question before
you know Matt would do better than I can
with the actual statistics but how many
nuclear weapons would there have existed
in history
60,000 70,000 something like that why so
many most of them were thermonuclear
weapons you don't need a lot of
thermonuclear weapons what would you be
doing with 60,000 thermonuclear weapons
in the first place it was ridiculous
it was Reagan who asked this question
why so many why particularly after a
decade of negotiations with the Soviet
Union on the limitation of strategic
arms had their numbers not been limited
that was his fundamental criticism of
the salt process strategic arms
limitation that's why he wanted to kill
salt but of course he wanted to replace
it and did with start strategic arms
reduction talks and that was aiming
toward some concept of minimum
deterrence how many do you actually have
to have to achieve deterrence at the
same time Kenan was proposing really
quite independently of Reagan in 1981 a
50% cut in strategic weapons on both
sides and in this sense both Kenan and
Reagan were really going beyond what was
being talked about in the freeze
movement the nuclear freeze movement of
1982 you know which would have just
frozen existing deployments both quite
independent
the other are saying let's do deep cuts
dramatic cuts in weaponry so minimum of
deterrence is something that Reagan came
to and I'm sure he didn't know that it
was a Kenan idea he wouldn't have cared
whether it was a Kenan idea it just made
sense and that's why he came to it Kenan
on the other hand was totally unaware
that this is happening secondly no first
use cannon also in 1982 finally secured
the support of a few other cold warriors
Mac Bundy Robert McNamara and Gerard
Smith for his 1950 concept of no first
use which of course implied a
fundamental change in NATO strategy
which had always assumed first use even
though it didn't publicize that very
clearly this to compensate for the
Western Allies conventional force
imbalance disadvantage of course Reagan
at this time was devising something that
we could perhaps call no use at all
which goes beyond no first use and you
can see this in two things that Reagan
is pushing in 1982 and 1983 one is the
zero option proposal regarding theater
nuclear forces intermediate-range
nuclear forces in Europe instead of
limiting them let's abolish them Reagan
said and secondly and on a larger scale
the Strategic Defense Initiative of
March 1983 which by developing defenses
against nuclear weapons would Reagan
claimed make them impotent and obsolete
that then paralleled the first the third
Canon recommendation from the 1950s
which involved negotiations with the
Soviet Union looking toward the eventual
abolition of nuclear weapons altogether
and this is the great bombshell the
great shock of the wreck yulux Ummat in
1986 when the President of the United
States and the leader of the Soviet
Union suddenly to the astonishment of
their aides
discovered they had a common interest
which was let's get rid of them
altogether and the American documents
this is not widely known but it's in the
American documents it's Reagan the actor
Reagan is saying to Gorbachev well Mick
if we can just do this then we'll stage
another conference in Reykjavik ten
years hence and we'll both bring the
last atomic bomb with us and I'll be
very old Mick and you won't recognize me
and you'll say Ron is that you and I'll
say yes make it's me and I have the last
nuclear weapon here and so do you you
know who's playing this for all it was
worth
it didn't happen of course for various
reasons but the fact that that
discussion was taking place the fact
that they found so quickly such common
ground in this shifted the ground of the
entire debate and so nuclear abolition
ever since it has been on the table it's
been endorsed by all kinds of people who
in an earlier era would would have found
this a very surprising idea Palme it's a
later endorsed it
the primary advocates of it now as many
of you know are George Shultz and Henry
Kissinger these are not marginal figures
in the American grand strategic
establishment and so what was happening
here is that Reagan by asking simple
questions was moving back to Canada and
ultimately back to Klaus woods if
nuclear weapons served no rational
purpose then what was the rationale for
having nuclear weapons in the first
place the logic seemed child Blake too
many nuclear weapons sophisticates and
to some contend it still does today but
in this instance the child happened to
be the oldest man who had ever served as
president of the United States and this
made something of difference so that's
why Reagan is important
that brings us to the present situation
and where we might go from here in
thinking about nuclear weapons if I'm
right about this that Shakespeare and
Clausewitz saw how means could destroy
ends long before nuclear weapons were
developed and how Kenan and Reagan and
many people afterwards after them also
saw this having knowledge of nuclear
weapons and is there not some deeply
embedded logic here which has to do with
whatever you might call it genetic
propensity to survive simple common
sense whatever it might be there seems
to be something deeply embedded in the
way that not just states are run but the
way that people think or at least
intelligent people are rational people
think so that's one way of looking at
this another way of looking at it is
just say oh no we've just been lucky
this could all blow up at any point and
that was what was being demonstrated in
Matt's scenario this afternoon which it
is whichever it is I think this really
is beginning to get at the heart of the
post Cold War debate with respect to
grand strategy which it seems to me
should certainly be talking about
abolition as a long-term objective but
with the recognition that abolition is
not going to come anytime soon and maybe
even in our lifetime for the simple
reason that people possess nuclear
weapons for different reasons some do it
because they out of habit because there
are holdovers from the Cold War
that's the Americans and the Russians
some do it because they believe it's
absolutely vital to their
survival that's the Israelis some do it
in very much the way that nasty children
build stink bombs in school as a way of
getting attention that's the North
Koreans you can decide for yourself
where the Iranians fit within this
category I would not I don't know it
would not attempt to say but the point
is people have different motives for
hanging on to nuclear weapons and that's
why I think even though everyone might
endorse the concept of evolution at the
same time it's unlikely to happen
anytime soon
I've often thought this is my own class
we'd see a nightmare I've often thought
it would take the detonation of a
nuclear weapon somewhere or of several
to actually create that common interest
in quick abolition and I'm not sure that
we need to pay that price or should want
to pay that price on the other hand I'm
not content with the status quo not
content with where we stand now because
the knowledge of nuclear weapons is
proliferating there still is a perfectly
good question to ask why does the United
States
I do the United States and the Soviet
Union need still whatever it is 3,000 on
both sides it's way way down from what
it was but why 3,000 as opposed to 30
and why in the first place I mean do the
Russians and the Americans really plan
to get into a war with one another and
if they did would they fight it with
nuclear weapons in the first place there
is a kind of absurdity in hanging on to
these things and probably the only
reason that we are doing it apart from
force of habit and lack of imagination
is the concern about reducing our
Arsenal's to the point at which they
would begin to approximate those of
China or of France or India Pakistan or
whatever that's the spec that's part of
it as well so I'm skeptical about
abolition as a practical goal I'm not
content with the status quo either and
I'm thinking about a middle way
and here I'm very much influenced by
Kenan and we're containment fit within
the range of options that existed within
the United States government in 1945
1946 so many people at that time believe
that there were only two options either
war with the Soviet Union or the
appeasement of the Soviet Union and it
was very hard for people to think what
might lie in between and that was Kenan
Strait contribution the idea of
containment a strategy for stabilizing
the situation and strategy for waiting
for long-term historical forces to solve
this problem without war and without
appeasement and indeed that was his
great contribution that's the great
achievement of the Cold War so my
question is and this is what I want to
leave you with is whether in looking at
nuclear strategy in looking at our
discontent with the way things are now
in looking at our sense of how
unrealistic
however praiseworthy the goal of
abolition might be is there some middle
way which should be the objective of
American policy and should at the same
time to the greatest extent possible be
the objective of international
cooperation non-proliferation I think
may be a loser in the way it has been
traditionally conceived because it still
fundamentally depends on the have powers
telling other nations they cannot have
nuclear weapons
anybody who has raised children notes
the futility of a strategy like that and
Parenthood and relations between parents
and children is not a bad way of
thinking about some of the problems that
we confront with regard to nuclear
weapons today by directing attention to
the problem by saying we won't allow you
to have them by saying we're going to
impose sanctions on you if you get them
what we're really saying is that we're
going to swat you over the head but of
course you never actually do that with a
child anyway so the traveler gets away
with a lot and that's part of the
problem that is happening
and I think in this regard right now
well what if we were to go a different
route what if we were to back off again
thinking sometimes about how parents
deal with children one of the things
that works pretty well in dealing with
the child the child is about to do
something stupid or nasty or dumb or you
know some other way offensive and you
have said it repeatedly
don't do it don't do it don't do it and
the kid is going ahead and doing it
anyway why not just say to the kid all
right
what the hell go ahead and do it and
then see what happens and then see where
you're gonna be and whether it's the
stink bomb in class or any number of
other things that one might think of
very often it's a salutary lesson to a
child because they discover that what
they really have been interested in
doing is rebelling against a third but
they don't have an interest in stinking
at the house or the classroom or whatnot
or life is going to be unpleasant if
they do these things and so on in other
words back off the instruction the
admonition and simply ask the question
what do you do after you do that I think
that's a very fundamental class whitson
question I think that was the question
that Clausewitz was asking brand
strategists to consider remember
Clausewitz was in the russian army at
the time of Napoleon's invasion and
fought in the Battle of Borodino and
actually makes a cameo appearance in
Tolstoy his war and peace page 776 or
something like that only one one
paragraph from budgets there but what a
class was learnt from Napoleon in
marching to Moscow in 1812 and equity
learned was that Napoleon did not ask
the then what question what do you do
then what after you've got there back in
the golden age when I taught at the
Naval War College we had a term for the
it was called the dog and car problem
dogs spend a lot of time chasing cars
but rarely know what they would actually
do with a car if they were to catch one
and that's the kind of question that
grand strategists ought to be asking of
those who are doing things that we
consider offensive it's also a question
we should be asking ourselves so you do
it whatever it is then what what is the
next step what is the next stage I'm
inclined to think that's the great
weakness of terrorists because they
don't ask that question they don't have
a plan that's why ultimately they tend
to lose support I think it's fascinating
to ask what would have happened if Ben
Latin had asked that question before
orchestrating the 9/11 attack maybe he
did ask that question it's not
completely clear what he intended the
result of that to be but I'm pretty sure
he did not intend what the result has
actually been which is that the United
States is much more effective in
countering terrorism the presence of the
United States in the Middle East is not
diminished if anything it's been
enhanced over the last decade what with
the war in Iraq we have not lost many
allies in Middle East we have gained
some positions yes we've lost people
yes we've lost prestige yes we have lost
a lot through the inefficient management
of what we were trying to do but we have
also learned a lot and that has been
evident in the performance the
remarkable performance of the American
military in the last of three or four
years it's extraordinary what has
happened in this regard none of these
things I think could have been on bin
Laden's list of what I want to have
happen on his then what list
so it seems to me that this is something
that a grand strategist should be doing
it's something we should be teaching our
students to do when they think about
grand strategy is to push that can down
the road just one more step and say ok
if you do that
what and perhaps this kind of question
might bring us back to something that is
as I said earlier the most extraordinary
achievement of the Cold War which is
that nuclear weapons were developed but
not used it's because so many people so
many leaders had the good sense or were
frightened into asking the then what
question if we use nuclear weapons
whether in Korea or in Vietnam or in
Afghanistan or against India or against
Pakistan or whatever then what and
nobody could answer that question and
that's where nuclear weapons have
deterrent capability that I think is
often underestimated then because it
leads not to the deterrence of another
nation but it leads to self-determine
now if we could focus more on that if we
could publicize that history a lot if we
could perhaps find a way to say this in
our own government statements instead of
going around and saying thou shalt not
just say well what do you expect what
happened next you see then I think we
might be getting somewhere
admittedly it's gonna be hard to say
this to the Israelis but one should and
they probably have answers
conventional forces etcetera maybe
there's an argument to be made for
making special provision for countries
that are in the position of feeling that
they have no recourse other than to
resort to nuclear weapons for their
defense I'm not persuaded Israel is in
that situation but let's say it were in
that situation in that case maybe there
ought to be an Atlantis maybe there
ought to be a security umbrella that the
United States provides to Israel this
would change nothing there's been one
for the last 40 years or so it just
hasn't been formal but something like
that might be an edge
- this kind of strategy but I'm just
saying here and here's where I will wind
up is that there's much to be learned
from asking simple questions of complex
issues to ask complex questions of
complex issues is to tie yourself up and
knots and academics are extraordinarily
good at doing that somebody somewhere
somehow needs to back off and ask simple
questions the child who sees that the
emperor has no clothes the president who
says why do we have to have so many
nuclear weapons why do we have to have a
cold war why is defense and all of these
are childlike questions but
extraordinarily important questions and
I just conclude with the suggestion that
the ability to ask these kinds of
questions is fundamental to how one
should think about grand strategy to
help one should train young people to
think about grand strategy and certainty
to how anyone should think about what
has been the topic of today's session
and this summer's seminar thanks very
much
all right thank you John thank you so
much those who'd like to pose questions
we'd ask you to come to the the center
here and use the microphone since we
were live-streaming these lectures so
thank you so much I have two questions
first of all it's interesting to hear
your characterization of Ronald Reagan
which of course many will differ with
quite strongly how do you see Reagan
dealing as you know when he was elected
there was a tremendous thrust in the
political forces of Representatives camp
such as the committee at present danger
making rather alarming comments about
nuclear war and one could interpret SDI
differently as a measure to as let's say
adopt a counter force strategy which was
clearly articulated by the Reagan folks
how do you see that in terms of
factoring into the picture you painted
and secondly why should what are we
supposed to do now a simple question if
a middle-range power
decides to acquire nuclear weapons
because it feels it has to protect
itself against American conventional
superiority sure what how do we answer
that kind of situation let me take both
of those first of all Reagan like great
grand strategists thought in sequence he
didn't try to do everything at once
he thought about actually a chain of
actions that one would take you would do
one thing and that would produce certain
results and then you would do something
else what he was following in this
period was what was known as the it
really goes back to Dean Acheson in the
early days of the Cold War and negotiate
from spring that was the catch phrase
that was used all the way through the
Cold War but the way I just understood
that and so did Nitsa and a lot of other
cold warriors was that you never got
enough strength to negotiate so you're
just always building strength and you
never negotiated what Reagan said was
that yes we're going to build strength
because
the perception of strength and to some
extent the reality of strength had
eroded in the 1970s and so they had to
be built and in fact we were gonna build
up enough of it so that the Soviet Union
would come to see that it could not
compete and then it would be ready to
negotiate that would be real negotiation
from strength it would be a two-stage
process not a one-stage process as
Patterson had defined it what's the
evidence for this the evidence for this
is the remarkable radio addresses that
Reagan was himself writing throughout
the late 1970s there are I think about
1,500 longhand pages of Reagan's writing
on all kinds of issues he had those
speechwriter so he was working these
things out for himself they have since
been published in a book edited by Kyra
and Skinner they actually constituted
laying out a grand strategy before he
became president something he was
working out in his own mind at that time
and this was very much a part of it in
fact I would challenge you to name me
any other president in the 20th century
who so carefully wrote out his plan his
ideas before taking office I can't think
of any I have to go back a long distance
to find somebody who wrote that much
about what he was going to do and was
trying to think through what he would do
before he got in that position that's
the evidence for it and you can look it
up it's been published now the other
question was what do we actually do if a
small power or a middle power actually
gets a nuclear weapon well we have some
test cases already that we can draw on
from history in this regard the answer
is has been nothing up to this point
when China was on the verge of getting
an atomic bomb this was considered
extraordinarily de
because this is back they got the bomb
in 1964 and in 62 63 this was the great
nightmare of American grand strategist
because the Chinese were thought to be
crazy and so the Kennedy administration
actually approached the Soviet Union
with a view to jointly launch launching
a joint pre-emptive attack Soviet and
American this was just months after the
Cuban Missile Crisis that would take out
the Chinese test facilities and prevent
the Chinese from getting a nuclear
weapon and in the end it didn't happen
partly because the Russians were
skeptical and partly because the Chinese
tested their their bomb how did the
Chinese behave after they got the bomb
well actually pretty cautiously pretty
carefully I think one has to say to the
point that when the Russian suggested
something similar to Nixon in 1969 let's
act together to take out the Chinese
nuclear capability Nixon said the
national security of China is vital to
the national security of the United
States a huge flip so that's one case
that's fascinating to look at we have a
more recent case which is North Korea we
said repeatedly we will not allow Kim
jong-il to get a nuclear weapon
now Kim jong-il got a nuclear weapon a
couple years ago it doesn't work very
well
tends to fizzle more than what he's got
one
he's probably got several at this point
what have we done nothing we've learned
to live with it we've assumed that he
has the capability to ask the then what
do you do next question and I suspect
probably he does it hasn't really
changed the strategic balance on the
Korean Peninsula because the great
danger has always been not his nuclear
weapons but his conventional force
capability directed against Seoul his
artillery and so on we certainly have
taken actions to prevent him from
proliferating that technology elsewhere
and that probably is more effective than
it used to be but can we say that the
religion is any great change in the
strategic situation in North Korea is
Kim jong-il more popular more successful
more admired as a world statesman for
having done this what has it got him you
know it's the then what question that
comes up so historically that's been our
answer now the question that has to
arise here is always what about the
situation where somebody gets one and
then actually proposes to use it so far
the record has been sufficiently
reassuring that certain political
scientists have tried to turn this into
a theory and say proliferation of
nuclear weapons has been such a
stabilizing thing we should be
encouraging I I think not I think this
is what happens when political science
runs amuck sooner or later something
will go wrong sooner or later
something that will happen and we
certainly need to be thinking about how
we would deal with that situation but I
come back to the point that I made in
the top it hasn't been very effective
saying thou shalt not acquire nuclear
weapons because that seems only to
encourage people to do so so perhaps a
different psychology would be more
effective to simply point out well what
good are they and I think we ought to
ask that question more often
it's like the the line at fairway in
your recent article on abolishing
tyranny you you argue strongly that
democracy is not necessarily indicated
for countries that don't have the
preconditions to have a democracy
particularly you talk about the Middle
Eastern countries in Central Asia I'm
sorry which recent article is the cycle
abolishing tyranny oh that one okay it's
not yes two years old three years old
two years old that's the most one all
right finally you're right it is the
most reasonable yes and so you speak you
argue strongly against it as well as you
approach perishing you publish less so
my question is is the Obama
administration making exactly that
mistake in Afghanistan can the United
States are we doing the right thing in
Afghanistan and if not what should we be
doing well first of all I think the
Obama administration is doing something
very interesting that has not been as
fully commented on as it should have
been it's not talking very much about
promoting democracy sure there is some
rhetoric and you can find references to
this in the new national strategy
statement to made 2010 which you can
find references to everything in the new
national strategy statement that's what
they're for they're like telephone
directories you know the Obama
administration certainly has not pushed
the idea that both the Clinton and the
Bush administration's pushed that there
is a global trend toward democratization
the influence of Fukuyama on both the
democratic administration of Clinton and
Republican administration Bush I think
was profound in this Obama paradoxically
has come back to I think a Kissinger
Ian's view of the world which is that
democracy is not automatically the best
solution for every country it's not
culturally
rooted everywhere it's not historically
determined in order to maintain
international order one has to deal with
some non democratic states it's not even
predetermined now that capitalism and
markets can only flourish in democratic
states because that's what the Asians
have proved this is the Lee Kuan Yew
approach you know and that's kind of
where it started but look where it's
gone much beyond Singapore and that
could be an extraordinarily important
thing that some system other than
democracy could actually be more
effective at organizing an economy
that's going to be the huge question of
the 21st century Obama has been smart
enough to recognize this complexity and
to acknowledge it and simply to talk
less about this kind of democratization
rhetoric so he is much more in the
tradition of John Quincy Adams in 1821
we go abroad we go not abroad in search
of monsters to destroy people can follow
our example if they choose but we will
not force it on them so this is the John
Quincy Adams tradition curiously both
Bill Clinton and George W Bush were in
the Woodrow Wilson tradition of actually
going out and promoting democracy
sometimes by force I'm actually more
comfortable with the John Quincy Adams
tradition and I think it's fascinating
that a supposedly Liberal Democratic
administration is coming around to a
kind of a Kissinger Ian met or Nicky and
balance of power view sure I mean there
are some who would say that your work
your ideas had some influence in the
Bush administration one idea was that
the US should try to end tyranny in our
time the only influence that took place
on that was it made its way into the
inaugural address and that's because I
happen to be down meeting with the
speech writers 10 days before the
inaugural address and I was listening to
several other blowhard professors who
were going on much too long and so I
finally you just raised my hand and I
said wanting to stop those guys I said I
think the president ought to say we
should end tyranny in our time when and
I put my hand and I can see my cursing
his speechwriter and the next thing I
knew it was on television so did they
did they follow through no that was the
point of the article that I wrote which
is you know it was rhetoric that was
never really followed through my point
about ending journey was that this comes
there is more of a common impulse to end
tyranny than there is to promote
democracy we may say that there is a
universal desire for democracy I'm not
convinced of that is there a universal
desire for tyrants I don't think so so
if we're thinking about universal
principles my point was this is a better
place to start but it doesn't mean that
the tyrants you remove will all then be
replaced by Democrats and so this is
really you know
vague way the Obama administration is
coming around to this but not by way of
having read my book or having listened
to that speech I knew that this would be
extremely thought-provoking and I just I
want to thank you all my hopes thank you
this being thought-provoking I grew up
during the Cold War I see some other
people here also probably grew up during
the Cold War I think a lot of people
have forgotten the Cold War better red
than dead you know there's this intense
desire among a lot of people to have
resolution and that's where better read
the dead came from but you know as you
were speaking about Kenan and his coming
up with this seminal idea of containment
and what it was grounded in is there any
doubt that the Nobel Peace price would
be not enough really for him in terms of
the power of an idea making probably
what you said this incredible
achievement of our not dropping the bomb
after the bomb was dropped yeah
oh there is there is something though
and then that also goes into then the
80s and with Ronald Reagan uh with the
euphemism for the Strategic Defense
which was Star Wars you know which some
people remember and I do believe that it
that the concept of Star Wars even
though they weren't able to implement
that technologically did restrain the
Soviet you know sure is that your
question Mike my question is this
this deals with colleagues that you are
friends with with the rise and decline
of great nations and towards the end of
your discussion and analysis you talked
about and I do believe that our military
has learned a lot nonetheless I see
continuing decline in America I like I
look around and I wonder what went wrong
with our country all right let's make
sure to bring it because there are
people behind you'd also like to ask
questions sir right could we make that
your question well I like to ask that
about half a sentence it'll become a
real question I the way I see it is even
though right now we don't look that bad
in terms of how we're performing as a
nation I see that the decline of America
economically our dependence on my sake
all right I have to cut you off now sir
please allow him to answer if you're
right thank you please as a possibility
that that could work out not good for
America okay let me just take one part
of that statement and focus back on
Kenna and the sources of his insight
because you said you thought it was
remarkable that he was able to see that
far as such an early stage and I think
that's true as well and one of the
things that I'd been very curious about
and is most of you probably know I'm
canons biographer and so it's a project
I've been working on for decades and
knew him very well and one of the issues
I've been wrestling with is part of
these insights come from and
increasingly I'm coming around to the
realization that they came as much from
literature as they did from the study of
history or statecraft
and hence the Shakespeare that shows up
in the quote that I was talking about
but also one of the things that I found
in going through his notes from the
summer of 1946 and in looking at his
first speech at an American University
which took place at Yale in October of
1946 and he's laying out the containment
thesis about a third of the speech is
about Chekhov and why well he loved
Chekhov he wanted to be check-offs
biographer he never was I think what he
saw in Chekhov was a window into the
Russian character and he really did
believe in national character that's why
he thought containment would work
because the Soviet Union was an
artificial Express's on traditional
Russian national character and he
accessed traditional Russian national
character through his study at the
language and the culture and
particularly by reading Chekhov and
Tolstoy and the CF ski and so on and so
forth but I think what really led him to
appreciate Chekhov it's just how
restrained Chekhov is those of you've
tried to read read Chekhov you know
probably had the for the first reaction
was my reaction for years this is just
boring and then only after you really
get into this do you realize that really
interesting things are happening in a
very quiet way behind the scenes it's
all contained and I think it was that
that really appealed to George and led
him to think about then how did this
transfer over into how you would deal
with Russian someone so I can't prove
this but I know of several different
instances in which the really great
ideas tend to be started from literature
more than from history with one
exceptions one historian who was
immensely influential but it was Edward
Gibbon and
decline of the Roman Empire not recent
history that okay hello sir thank you
for coming how do my first question is a
lot of two questions the first question
is to what extent do you think do you
believe a study of the pattern of
proliferation of other a symmetric means
of warfare would benefit our
understanding of you know kind of like
the enriching our understanding of the
range of options available you know for
putting a stop to nuclear weapons and
I'm thinking of you know chemical
weapons now that have been banned but
even then I mean there's still always
the there's always a question of the
dirty bomb well it's funny you mention
that because this actually came up in
the simulation this afternoon there was
a moment where I just suddenly unloaded
on the students and I said why can't
there be more thought given to how the
study of previous asymmetric conflicts
might inform our understanding of how to
deal with nuclear terrorism and I think
it's a great question and I think it
could and I'm not gonna do it I have
other things to do but I think somebody
should asymmetrical warfare is an
ancient concept it's not been ended
recently you will find it in sunset and
the art of war so it's always been there
so I think there is much to be learned
from going back and thinking about this
but thinking about it without getting
bogged down in the detail and that's
what is is what so often happens in
academic courses is that they get bogged
down in detail and they don't look at
the comparison so how does Sun Zhu and
his view of asymmetrical warfare relate
to let's say the asymmetrical warfare of
the Russian guerrillas who were
harassing Napoleon on his retreat and
how does that relate to the American
Indian Moors and then how does all of
that relate to what was what we were
doing in the Philippines hundred years
ago how does that relate to the at Nam
etc etcetera how does it relate to
Afghanistan there are plenty of cases
out there for looking at asymmetrical
warfare and how it's been handled how
transferable
those would be to the nuclear issue I
don't know but I think it would
certainly be worth somebody looking into
it and giving it some thought because I
do think that these patterns of strategy
do persist or do exist over large
periods of time and space and I think
many of the problems that seem new to us
really aren't if you allow for the
change in technology so I would
certainly endorse what you said I think
that's a very good way to go I think
that could be a whole project for
another of Matt's summer seminars for
sure okay also I read your book
strategies of containment and
I didn't quite find us maybe so I wanted
to ask this question that what do you
think or did it did the question of you
know the number of nuclear testing that
took place around the world and kind of
the proportion to other countries doing
it and with thee and then to that of the
United States do the number of tests
with the United States like if that was
also kind of factored into the thinking
of
well I don't really talk about that in
strategies of containment I get a little
more into it in we now know the 1997
book what certainly happened was that
nuclear testing was polluting the
atmosphere and there was concern about a
nuclear winter and there was concern
about ready is this is happening as
early as the 1950s the whole issue of
strontium 90 in the mid 50's was leading
people to think about the medical
consequences of nuclear testing that's
why I went underground that's why the
Test Ban Treaty of 1963 and the Russians
and the Americans could agree on that
and so that's that's nuclear testing is
one of the early factors that certainly
led to the emergence of this common
sense of danger it seems to me so those
sort of standing I think will be the
last ones to get to pose questions we're
already almost over so please be brief
if you could in your question thank you
for your very insightful address thank
you if in a nucleons by what what you
mean by grand strategy is addressing an
existential threat which is put on that
existential threat in the cold war
between the US and Soviet Union
disappeared when Soviet Union
disapproved so the problem was solved
historical political problem was solved
yep through the through a political
historical process not through
negotiating reductions in nuclear
weapons correct now you've written
extensively on Korea I know
remember that very excellent article
you've had in a curious book which you
discuss Soviet and American attempts at
unification and overcoming division in
this particular instance since you
raised Kim jong-il and nuclear weapons
do you see the need to resolve that
historical political problem on the
Korean Peninsula in order to resolve the
nuclear issue or can it be resolved or
can the nuclear should be resolved
proliferation it should be resolved
without pressing your story that's
that's a good question I don't think
we're going to resolve
we can't resolve the nuclear
proliferation question with regard to
North Korea because the proliferation is
already taking place they've got the
bomb so that's a fait accompli I don't
think they're gonna do much with it I
don't think they have capability to do
much with it I still think that they're
a sin the whole is the all the artillery
that's within range of Seoul that's
really the insurance that they're buying
not that they're gonna you know take out
Los Angeles or something like them I
think it was done for prestige reasons
it was done to attract attention Kim
il-sung doesn't Kim jong-il sorry does
not like to be out of the news and so he
always finds some way to get into the to
get into the news I think it's pretty
simple as that I would say the Koreans
have got to solve the issue of the
future of the peninsula on their own I
don't think we can solve that for them
it's been there for a very long time I
don't think it's permanent but I'm
surprised that it has lasted as long as
it has since the end of the Cold War
there are some things that I think are
permanent actually they're just always
going to be with us one is Fidel Castro
has had a remarkable recovery from his
illness and just appeared a healthy and
vital again you know that guy's going to
live 150 years but most of these issues
sooner or later will be soft and on
Korea you know this is this is one where
we just try to keep it from blowing up
but it's hard to say that time is
working in favor of the North Korean
regime I think I would say one of the
thing not to be blackmailed into
sustaining that regime and I think that
to some extent we have which is every
time Kim tests a weapon or threatens to
test a weapon or whatnot you know we
ship in more food
supplies and all of that I think there
ought to be some hard questions about
the extent to which we do that but that
that's the only real modification I
would make in that strategy yeah I
wanted to ask you a question about why
the administration's sing about Iran and
North Korea and in the posture of you
recently and what the what their
rationale is for doing that and second
of all what the effects with that well I
don't know the answer to the first one
you would have to ask the administration
you know as far as that goes I wondered
why the Bush administration singled out
the three states that it did as the axis
of evil it seems to me there were a lot
of other plausible candidates around if
you wanted to talk about evils so you
know I don't know the answer to that
other than that you know there is the
obvious concern about these being
quote-unquote irrational actors
irrational powers at Medina Judd and Kim
jong-il I'm not convinced that they are
irrational I think they're actually
pretty shrewd much of the time and it's
just that we can't control them and so
we consider them dangerous in the
Iranian situation I think is much more
dangerous than the North Korean
situation of course so I think it's in a
different category there but I think
some of the same mentality still may be
working these are both failed States one
is a failed state the other is coming
close to being a failed state and fail
states need to buy a certain amount of
insurance should we single them out as
being the most important problems that
confront us I doubt I think we had I
have a whole spectrum of problems that
we are thinking about and I think
singling them out is playing into their
hands to a considerable
extent I think there's some other things
that are at least as dangerous what's
happening in Mexico for example and
whether you want to single these out and
talk about them or not is a good
question but just to give the illusion
that we just had two problem countries
or something like that no we have a lot
of problems
all right well John I can't help but
think you're in some eerie way seems to
anticipate the subject for next summer
public health in the next pandemic so
thank you for this one of the most
graceful way to end so so thank you so
much for coming coffin all and and thank
you all hope to see you next time
you